okay today I'm going to talk to you
about alkanes and alkenes now we're
going to learn how to name them we're
going to learn how to draw them we're
going to learn about the fundamental
differences between them and how to test
for each one so first of all what are
alkanes and alkenes now basically put
they are hydrocarbons now a hydrocarbon
is a molecule that only contains
hydrogen and carbon hence the name
hydrocarbon let's have a look at a real
fundamental difference between the two
now the big big difference is alkanes
only contains single bonds those single
bonds here as shown by these lines
however alkenes contain a double bond
this is shown by this this symbol right
here to show that there are two bonds
between these two carbon atoms now the
way I remember this is because the word
alkene has an e in it right here and
this looks like an equal sign so I
always think alkene equal sign so we
need to know how to name these now
there's a nice pattern that we can
follow whenever there's one carbon we
know that the word the name for it is
going to start with math if it's if
there's two carbons we know it's going
to start with F and if it's got three
carbons we know it's going to start with
this probe so let's have a quick look at
the two we've got here so first of all
the alkane i can see i've got one two
carbons therefore it's going to start
with s and also i'm then going to see
well is it an alkane or an alkene well
it hasn't got any double bonds so
therefore it's an alkane so i know that
this is if a methane similarly if I look
at this alkene right here to name it I
could see I've got one two carbons so
again this one's going to start with
eath but this time I have a double bond
I know it's an alkene so it's going to
be a me Fein so this is e Thame so
that's a hydrocarbon
with no double bonds and two carbon
atoms and this is he theme this is my
alkene with two carbons and a double
bond so how do we go about drawing them
now let's say I wanted to draw propane
now I can see again because it's got
this word probe in it I know it's going
to have three carbon atoms one two three
because it's an alkane I know there's
going to be no double bonds so it's
going to look like this and how do I
know how many hydrogen atoms to draw
around it well each carbon atom can only
have or needs to have four bonds so the
moment this one's just got one bond
attached to it so I need to draw in
these other hi genomes like with this
carbon here I've got two bonds so I just
need another two to make it four bonds 1
2 3 4 and for this carbon a carbon atom
here I've got 1 bond so I need another 3
like this propane now if I had to go and
try and draw propane let's think about
how I'd go about doing this so this time
I've got an alkene on my hands also
because it's got the word probe in it I
know it's gonna have three carbon atoms
again 1 2 3 this time though it's an
alkene so I know that this contains a
double bond notice how it only contains
one double bond and not a double bond
here as well so let's try and fill in
the rest of the the hydrogen atoms on
this molecule of propane so I can see
this carbon here already has two bonds
so it needs two more to make up for also
please notice how every hydrogen only
forms one bond let's have a look at this
central carbon we've got 1 2 3 bonds so
only needs one more and this one here we
have one bond so we need three more to
make it up to form so there I have a
propane now let's say I was in a
laboratory and I had a sample of an
ether and a sample of ethene but I
didn't know which one was which how I
could test for it is using
this stuff called bromine water now
bromine water only reacts with ething
because it's unsaturated so bromine
water can actually kind of react with
these double bonds and what we'd observe
is if we had a bromine water to an
alkene this bromine water would turn
colorless now notice how I said
colorless and not clear because you can
for example have a clear blue solution
or a clear orange solution what
colorless means is without any color so
how we describe water for example as
being colorless now the reason why
bromine water doesn't react with an
alkane is because there's no double
bonds to react with so we can say that
our Canes we described as being
saturated which means they don't have
any double bonds whereas my alkene is
unsaturated which means it does have a
double bond in this case it would react
with bromine water to turn colorless now
he fain would just remain if we added
bromine water to our ethane or any
alkane it would just remain the color of
bright bromine which is kind of orange
or brown the way or a member of
saturated and unsaturated is s for
saturated s for single bonds so those
are the differences between a falcon and
an alkene this is how to name them this
is how to draw them and this is the test
for it right there thank you